tell us about the announcement why get
into batteries well Tesla has always
been into batteries they're real kind of
value add is their lithium-ion battery
technology that they use in their
electric cars what they announced this
evening is that they are moving beyond
cars to batteries for the home
commercial businesses and the utility
grid how much do they cost Dana how much
is it gonna cost us to buy one of these
batteries if you want one of the home
ones
well the real vision is that you'll have
solar panels on your roof a Tesla car in
your driveway and a Tesla battery in
your garage it's a small sleek colorful
kind of wall-mounted unit it comes in
different colors that match the colors
of the Model S and for the smallest one
it's about $3,500 the utility scale
battery it's a little bigger
just give us an idea of the scale of
this battery well there's not just one
battery Tesla's proposition is that it
can stack as many batteries as you need
so utilities like Southern California
Edison encore Pacific Gas & Electric
that want to have pilot projects or try
these batteries on their grids can
basically order as many as they need and
Tesla can package them in a skid
depending on the utilities needs so
there's not just like one solution it's
a variable solution depending on the
customers need and is that demand for
these for these batteries already are
the large customers already lining up to
put in their orders there are I mean
energy storage has been the holy grail
of the utility industry for quite some
time as you know the Sun doesn't shine
all the time and it's not always windy
so we have incredible renewable Jenner
renewable energy resources that cannot
be captured and storage is the
technology solution to do that Tesla is
kind of coming into energy storage and
adding a big consumer facing brand to a
technology that is really kind of ripe
for expansion and several utilities in
the United States are looking the
storage as a way to kind of solve the
challenge that they have of integrating
more renewables onto the grid big day
for Elon Musk what did you ask him Dana
I asked him two questions I asked if
they would be bidding on utility RFPs
directly and it sounds like at the
moment they are primarily battery
suppliers to a wide variety of
developers and are working on pilot
projects with utilities directly I also
asked him if there was a chance that
Tesla would drop motors from the name of
the company and just simply become Tesla
and he didn't totally answer that
question but he did reveal that they
have registered Tesla energy calm as a
domain name